today we are doing the opening credits
sequence i always have dance sequences
in everything i've ever done
the actors were great on this they all
took a lot of time rehearsing the dance
the song it posits a question
and that question is do you want to
taste it
[Music]
we are dancing to wig worms do you want
to taste it it's 80s glam hairband metal
i don't know if i'd call it a specific
style let's call it a peacemaker grief
charissa has created something that's
reminiscent of those old comic books
when you see the guys go pow and they
they move in these very angular ways
a lot of the movement is actually rooted
in modern dance combined with maybe a
little bit of street style some of this
stuff also influenced by charlie chaplin
foster keaton
it's a little bit like if claymation was
in human form
it's really cool because we're all so
different that's what's fun so to see
this choreography on many different body
types in different ages and ethnicities
is really fun i'm very excited to be
able to create an opening that was very
very different from anything else on tv
and anything else in the dc world for
sure
[Applause]
you